Anoma del consiglio prego mini-stroke
brunettes and Leyla per Ola
Thank You mr. president president
honourable members when you next meet in
this chamber after this weekend this
will be a different primary this will be
a different union with one member less
this is not the choice of the council
nor the Parliament but we have to
respect it the withdrawal of the United
Kingdom will open a period of transition
a rather short one if the United Kingdom
intention remains not to seek its
extension before the 1st of July our
priority should therefore therefore be
too rapidly adopt a comprehensive
negotiation mandate and start
negotiations in order to build a new
relationship with the United Kingdom
that is as as close as possible by
balanced in terms of rights and
obligations the short duration of
transition period will unfortunately
make it more difficult to achieve a
widest ranging outcome by the end of the
year we therefore have to remain
prepared for all possible scenarios it
also seems that the current orientations
of the United Kingdom government are
adding to this complexity beat as
regards the end of free movement the non
participation in the single market or
the customs union or the intention to
diverge from regulatory perspective we
have to invest all efforts to avoid the
risk of a cliff edge and to ensure a
meaningful outcome of the negotiation
this autumn fortunately and regardless
of the outcome the withdrawal agreement
will continue to apply especially its
part to on citizens rights and the
various remedies foreseen should the UK
not deliver adequately in implementing
these provisions as we debated two weeks
ago having the withdrawal agreement in
force does not mean that we should rest
on our laurels as noted in
your resolution adopted on the occasion
a number of concerning regarding the
preservation of citizen rice have to be
addressed this will call for carefully
monitoring by the UK side as well as by
the Commission after implementing of the
prevail relevant provisions today your
voice vote will hopefully pave the way
for the next stage negotiating the terms
of the future relationship with the UK a
relationship for which the European
Council called for a comprehensive
mandate covering trade and economic
relations as well as external and
internal security likewise this
relationship should be underpinned by
strong governance and robust level
playing field provisions given the close
economic proximity of the United Kingdom
even if the core elements of the future
relationship notably the horizontal
provisions and governance and level
playing field can be agreed by the end
of the year the negotiations are
expected to take longer until all the
matters covered by the political
declaration have been addressed I
therefore welcome the step taken by the
Parliament to prepare itself within the
adaptation of the brakes it steering
group in a manner that will allow a
closer follow-up of the negotiation
process Parliament's resolution as well
as its engagement notably on citizens
rights have proved extremely useful
during the negotiation process we count
on this engagement to continue during
the transition period and later on and
indeed a large degree of convergence
revealed all along the brightest process
between the position of the Parliament
has developed in your various
resolutions and the priorities of the
Council whatever happens the good
cooperation between the EU institutions
must continue the European Parliament
will remain fully informed and involved
in accordance with the EU treaties I do
hope that you're in the negotiations to
come our common efforts and commonality
of purpose will provide the support
required by our negotiator and helped an
outcome to the benefit of the Union and
its citizens present honorable members
to conclude as I said at the beginning
of my intervention this is a special
moment a number of your colleagues
members of this house will be leaving I
know it is an emotional occasion for
many of you and I would like to
associate myself by addressing my
gratitude to the UK members of the
European Parliament for their
significant contribution to the work of
your institution and of the European
Union over the years and wish them well
for the future thank you for your
attention
grazie Presidente von der Leyen la la
parola no Mandela Commission Thank You
mr. president
honourable members as president of the
European Commission first of all I want
to pay tribute to all those British
people who contributed so much to almost
half a century of British EU membership
and I think of all those who helped to
build our institutions people like
Commission out of [ __ ] field was known
as the father of our single market or
Roy Jenkins president of the European
Commission who did so much to pave the
way for us single currency I think of
these thousands of European civil
servants of British nationality who
devoted their lives and their careers to
Europe and have done so much to build
our union they will always stay part of
our family
and I think of all those years so many
British MEP s have contributed to making
this Parliament and the Union strong you
have our gratitude and our respect even
more so for your resilience in the last
three and a half years we will miss you
but we will always keep up our
friendship with you and you can count on
us as we know that we can count on you
honourable members in the last plenary
session we discussed the issues of
citizens rights we will also be vigilant
on the implementation of the agreement
of in Northern Ireland the power sharing
of women in Northern Ireland gives us
hope that the spirit of cooperation will
continue to mark relations across the
border yet the withdrawal agreement is
only a first step from now on it's about
our new partnership with the United
Kingdom the negotiations are about to
start and just to be very clear I want
the European Union and the United
Kingdom to stay good friends and good
partners the story is about old friends
and new beginnings and we have a lot in
common we both believe that climate
change needs to be fought as a matter of
urgency
they still scope to address these risks
but the window of opportunity is closing
so let's join forces in protecting our
planet we both understand that it takes
very little power to break a fragile
balance and to turn it into a full-blown
conflict but that the true power lies in
putting the pieces back together and
therefore we both believe in the power
of development cooperation and we know
that our security is interlinked and
here too we should join forces for all
these and
other reasons we want to forge a close
partnership but we also know that we
have to sort out how to deal with the
United Kingdom as a third country when
it comes to trade we are considering a
free trade agreement with zero tariffs
and zero kotas this would be unique no
other free trade agreement offers such
an access to our single market but the
precondition is that European and
British businesses continue to compete
on a level playing field we will
certainly not expose our companies to
unfair competition and it's very clear
the trade of is simple the more United
the United Kingdom does commit to uphold
our standards for social protection and
workers rights our guarantees for the
environment and other standards and
rules ensuring fair competition the
closer and better the access to the
single market and let me say that just
days ago some of the largest business
associations in Britain particularly in
the car and aerospace industry asked
their government to retain EU standards
and rules and I think this is in our
mutual interest this is about jobs it's
about common solutions for the world
market and I believe that the United
Kingdom and the European Union have a
mutual interest in the closest possible
partnership honourable members no new
partnership will bring back the benefits
of being part of the same Union but we
have the duty to seek the best for the
British and for the European people in a
post brexit world on our side will seek
best for industries and farmers across
our continent who ask for predictability
we will seek our best for young British
and young European students who want to
study and who want to live across the
channel and will seek the best for all
the researchers and scientists who want
to explore the unknown and work for
common solutions together in the
European Union as well as in the United
Kingdom we will devote all our energy
24/7 to come to results and to our
British friends and many perhaps not all
but many of our British MEP is here in
the room I want to use the words of the
famous British poet George Eliot she
said only in the agony of parting do we
look into the depths of love we will
always love you and we will never be far
long live Europe Grazia